kind of finding it hard to gather
thoughts right now because if you
haven't noticed there's a being snake on
my face
what are we doing today we're getting
snakes on I know you're so excited about
it we are going to try massage therapy
of snakes I read on the internet about
this thing called snake massages this
man looks so happy I can't even have to
have to it I'm gonna be like Esquire
networks Team Ninja Warrior challenged
the test friends to do something extreme
so I'm bringing in a 12 foot Python are
you sweating
yes honey my palms are sweating this is
a normal human reaction why do you think
people are afraid to think they bite
that snakes actually really docile if
you take care of him properly all right
so this is Casper and he's a ghost corn
smut oh he's adorable
Stanley the ball python and this is
Swasey the ball python maybe you want to
hold first oh wait
what's a good way to hold it okay okay
wow look at his eyes so scaly I've never
felt an animal that feels like this
before because that constrictor so he
likes to squeeze squeeze out the pain
Casper its face a [ __ ] I'm gonna throw
up or cry or something I don't know
I've okay with the snakes being on my
back I would prefer not to have snakes
on my boobs I'm gonna get the snakes on
my chest I think it'll be like getting a
hug let's do this it's gonna be dope
probably hopefully okay okay okay this
is not a sensation that I have
experienced before today oh my god is
going right by her face doesn't smell
that say that it feels kind of good Macy
I'm just chilling I could actually like
fall asleep Aviva you know what they
kind of feel like thin long ice packs
just moving across my body
yeah if I shut my eyes I do sort of goes
off it is very relaxing there's just
something about watching a snake move
that kind of makes me not just like
eating dough they were needing the
muscles on my chest ready
yeah I guess I want half acid
I put the snakes in my face I want a
snake scalp massage and I want it now
please take off your shirt going off the
brochure here so act like you don't like
it you ever seen a head more ready to
get a snake put on it all right let's do
this
comes Kasper okey-dokey my old pal
oh this already feels great yep there is
this one I'm getting goose bumps let's
just let's just put the snake oh yeah
yep yep okay I can hear him breathing oh
this is the best forgive me if I'm not
the most articulate he's going across my
eye pops you know you sometimes you hear
people breathing a new year but very
rarely a snake what what is the point of
this again what are the benefits I'm
proud of you burger it's working sofa
genuinely feels like this amazing
massage is just going to town right on
the old package I could have done that
for like four or five more hours so I
was already really really nervous and
freaking out like that I'm free
and then I'm laying there on the table
head down Ned tells me to turn around
and see the snake coming for me
and it is enormous oh wait is it a big
one oh my god no no no like the biggest
snake I've ever even dreamed up so this
is big worms all about and he's 50
pounds and I did not sign up for that at
all I thought they were little snakes it
was not gonna be a big deal uh even
thinking about it now I'm sorry okay oh
I don't know I'm not saying I was
freaking out the entire time I never got
used to it but I'm proud of myself that
I accomplished it and I did it and I
have it on video proof for the rest of
my life I was really scared at first but
he's really relaxing I mean as you can
see I don't want to let him go can I
take this guy hold Murphy yeah I'm very
proud of myself that I did
it did get more relaxing towards the end
it felt like a real massage you're not
scared of snakes then totally go for it
I dig them I would totally do this again
I'll stick with you I'm gonna get a
taste of my own medicine and see what
it's like